hello and welcome to design patterns
here on gotek tutorials today we're
going to look at a new pattern
called the proxy now what the proxy
essentially does is it puts a class in
front of your real process that adds on
a little additional functionality so
we're going to set up a new code spot
here
in our repo link down below
and we're going to get this ready okay
now with all our cmakes set up and go
ahead and start showing an example so
i'm going to write all the example code
here in this proxy folder we need a
subject to operate on i'm going to use
the idea of a store maybe an online
store and how they might or could tie
some of their services together
let's say from the store you buy
items that are for sale so we're going
to have class called item request
this is going to be an interface class
now what we want to do in this item
request is essentially have a base
request item
let's make this all now we got to think
about what happens when we request an
item and what we might be doing here if
we leave it pure virtual that
implementation is going to be left up to
whoever
implements this interface
but we could give it a root definition a
base definition in case no one overrides
it
let's go off an item skew for
simplicity's sake i'm just going to use
integers and i'm going to use an integer
called
item
skew
so essentially this would match with the
available items somewhere on a database
we're not going to build that database
but just to give you an idea of how it
works so you request an item and it
returns void that doesn't really work we
need to return something so what we
could do
is we could also have a
payment system so that way it uh charges
the payment system of course this would
probably be a more complicated struct
but we're just going to leave it as id
for now we could even do it as a string
just for
more details but
yeah i think overall if this were real
this would just be a struct that has
some details
in fact let's go ahead and build that
what would payment details have have we
basically want to know whether it's like
a bank or a card credit card let's just
go with like you know it's got to be
some kind of digital pass in there's no
physical here in the code world so cash
so the payment details
would have to be
some basic thing like that so to avoid
complications further
let's do some payment types
and we're going to
well we'll assume
a credit card and we'll have that
or maybe we'll also have wire
let's also put crypto in here
so let's say we accept those paper types
sounds good
uh payment deep tails is going to need a
type
and it's also going to need i guess
something else
so we'd have to think about how we're
putting this in here i think we're going
to return
just an integer or like the amount
charged so we could just have an
interface that's something like this
returns amount charged or zero if items
not found or payment could not be
okay well i guess we could have
different error codes amount charged
earns zero if item's not found earned
one if payment error well not one but
negative one
and we could go on here
returns negative two
well that's all we need for now
payment error or item not found sounds
good
so we have
this initial request item maybe we don't
well let's do this
if we pass this in by reference we can
edit their payment so we don't
necessarily want to do that so i think
we're going to make it cost and we're
going to take it in as a copy because we
don't want any risk of any of these
payment details getting changed you
could pass it in as a cost reference
and you think that might be fine because
well it's const
and i have a reference to the real thing
but the problem here is in c plus plus
it's a dangerous language you can you
can do a const cast and get rid of cost
and change the payment anyway
so for safety reasons we're just going
to take in a copy so they can't change
the real one coming in
and sure we'll make it constant
item skew doesn't matter so much but
we'll make it cost it's a less uh
security intensive asset
maybe we only need pay type but
um
yeah let's just go with pay type we
don't need this details after all
payment types is good enough
and in this code we're going to pseudo
code up a few things but pretend this is
talking to
some kind of database
so we go if
but you know before this we might
actually have to connect to something
like a database or
it would just be like that
let's go with inventory
and for this inventory
let's
type def inventory
as a vector of x
so now this is
just a vector
go ahead and conclude anything we need
up here
vector
so basically uh this would be more like
a database link but
it let's keep it simple so we go
something like
current
corey
got uh what is the function i forget
so we can use standard find here
starting at the beginning of the
inventory to the end of the inventory
and then what we're looking for which is
the item skew so if this returns
not the end
so it'd probably be better to do this on
its own line at first
a moment when you're too zoomed in just
trying to make sure it's invisible
all right
so this if this is not the end iterator
then we found it if bound is not equal
to our inventory
item
is in stock it's safe
so items it might be better to do items
in a way
where it's like
a sku
and we probably want a count of how many
are installed something like that
but then we need to think about ways to
clean it up because what if when it's
out of stock do we remove it from the
inventory or do we leave it there with a
zero so maybe that's getting a little
you know
in in the thick of it and gonna mess up
it for example
but if it's in stock we would check the
payment
so we need something here that would
talk to the uh the end too
let's just make a function to
pseudo that up
so we would go boy oh i guess items need
a price too don't they okay i'll get
this sorted out we'll make a problem
we're gonna have to skip over a lot of
details because
well
the reality of this example is
it's got to be simplified itself it's
going to get way too complicated if i
add every possibility and check every
angle
but it's just an example
uh let's go
charge so maybe we have a function use
called charge
takes the payment
and uh
i know how it's charged
for now we're just going to return
through
which assumes we charge the amount
uh from the proper
account now this payment type you're
gonna have to think of as being more
info like all the info to do the thing
so maybe it sends a request somewhere
else but for now we're just gonna assume
this succeeds no matter what and returns
true on the charge so
we would just go
vitamins and stock try to charge the
card
theoretically
pass in this payment
and an amount to charge and we don't
know how much it's going to be but we
would have to check based on this so
let's work this out after all
we'll just call it item
for sale
and that's what this inventory is going
to be a bunch of items for sale
let's have a sku let's have the cost
and let's also have
the uh in stock
from stock
that should be good now this gets a
little trickier because it's a current
inventory and we need instead of just
items view here it's obviously not going
to be able to find that so
we're going to have to put something
else here
now i believe what we can actually do
here is put a link up
and basically we just go through the
inventory and check does this allow let
me double check
okay if we want to do it this way you
have to find it and this would have to
take in an item const
item for sale just the members of this
vector basically
by reference
we'll just call it
and now in the body of this lambda we're
going to say if
i dot
sku rules it's u
and
i
dot
num stock is greater than zero
okay that's the face
we return
and that'll be all we need for the find
if code
so it implies that it returns cool we
want to make sure it understands that we
could uh put that here
like so
which is a part of the lambda optional
syntax otherwise we want to make sure we
actually return volts that's the follow
through case here
okay
so that's the default rest uh quest item
and you can see that uh well found is
going to be a little different with find
it because this returns
all of them match now we know it should
just be one but the thing is this is
going to be
let's see if it hovers over no it's
going to be
an iterator
so it's going to be a little bit
different
let's go ahead and just make sure this
compiles
it's uh
okay so if the item is found we
essentially want to return the amount
charged so that's all we would do
it's
found is greater than zero it means we
found an item in stock
now find if can
make quite a large
array or list or whatever you're working
with vector
but in our case there should only ever
be one match and one item in stock we
could make more sure of that with better
management of how this works but we're
kind of overlooking that because you
know technically we could make a bunch
of items with the same skew this should
be unique so we probably have something
to make sure that's unique so just
assume that
uh maybe we will even put that in here
assume
unique
sku
can't be multiple all right that's just
an assumption we'll make even though it
doesn't quite fit the data type
correctly
but uh let's just continue
so found that size is greater than zero
assume that the one in the front is a
one
so we'd return
cost per uh this only requests a single
item i guess you'd have to call it a
bunch of times to keep getting the same
thing
and once the amount is charged we want
to produce
the count of that so actually we do
found upfront
dot
so there we go
that would reduce the number in stock
however
it won't actually
because
this is just a copy it's not the real
inventory
so
that's not exactly going to work like we
think it will
this return is fine if we want to
actually reduce the front we might need
to use other methods
for me personally this whole find it
kind of complicates the whole thing uh
so i'm gonna just rewrite this in a
better
way that i like better so essentially we
just want to go through the inventory so
let's just do that so let's just make a
auto
reference to an item
and go to the inventory
and this is going to simplify a lot
because we can just do the direct check
item dot skew
if it equals
items view
and item dot
you know stop
straight up into it
and when you turn the item
down cost
and if it goes all the way through this
loop without returning a cost per
well let's make sure to reduce it so
this minus minus will work because it's
a reference to
this current inventory
so that will work properly and then
we'll return that and we're good to go
next time you go to check it's possible
that the num in stock is no longer
greater than zero and it won't find it
so that's an interesting thing so we can
return zero if item knocked down that
would be like right after this
now we don't
have the chart we need to charge right
um so we would do that
before subtracting the item
so if we find the item it's in stock and
we attempt to charge
so let's just go if
charge
that we need the payment passed in and
the amount to charge which is going to
be this item.cost per
so if this returns true
then we return all this stuff and say
charge went through
subtract the item
tell him how much we charged him
and if it doesn't go through so
it finds the item and in stock this
charge fails we want to return negative
one
that's a payment error
so there's our base request item this
should work pretty well
so this is an interface class but it's
not a pure virtual interface class since
we've defined request item you could do
in a pureversal way if you want i'll
leave that to you if you want a lot of
examples up there often do it that way
but
i don't find it to be necessary for this
more simple example all right
so we've essentially got a thing we can
use in our main and this is the real
item what we're going to do now is put a
proxy in front of it
so let's just test out the real one
first just to make sure it actually
works
so we need our payment type
our payment
our
just call this
storefront
payment storefront all right payment and
we need our payment to uh
well i guess we could be wherever we
want to be let's just do a credit card
right now
so
and then we just go r well we need to
populate the storefront it doesn't have
anything in it as you can tell
we could have it give it that base
substantiation of some stuff
right now it's just gonna be uh no items
actually for sale so maybe we went in
here and add inventory type of thing as
well
but uh
we've been a bit naive and haven't added
that let's just do it i guess add
inventory
and we just take in items for sale
and we could define this as just exactly
what you think current inventory don't
push back
for sale
we could make this virtual in case they
want to override it as well we're doing
that we probably want to make this
protected
rather than private
that way if you're inheriting you can
still write functionality around current
inventory
and there we go so
for now we can just
pass in a few items here something like
this
which was it was a skew cost in stock's
view
cost
number in stock
now is it gonna like that we have
instantiated this in line i don't know
it might confuse it a bit let's just put
in a couple of things here
so it kind of makes sense that uh we let
things stay in inventory with zero in
stock because that would kind of give us
a flag to replenish
if something runs out we try to get more
type of thing but that's that's for a
later
setup
let's see if this code actually
works
let me actually push this back
so the thing to do currently would you
know if you try to add inventory we got
to think about this a little bit if it
already exists so let's take this same
code here go through all the items
see if it matches
this new item's view
if it does
we would just add that to the inventory
with a plus equals
so we could just do that and of course
if this happens we want to be sure to
return not push back to one
so this would be
not allow duplicate
excuse instead
add to known in stock so there we go so
if it goes through all this and doesn't
find a duplicate then it just pushes
back a new one's a pretty
fine ad inventory at the quest there so
let's just go ahead and make sure this
runs i'm going to switch this to roxy
where's proxy i don't see it oh we need
to add it to one more cmake here
the level above it
be sure to add proxy here now it should
show up
as soon as this is done
there it is
okay and let's just hit play and make
sure everything succeeds we have an
error um
okay there's that can't have a return
type on a destructor
am i doing this type def wrong i think i
am i think i have reversed it's like
that
we say this item for sale it's called
let's try that now
i think this is okay
what's it complaining about
so we got an if statement
oh this item
we need a number in stock here minus
minus
and we need another parenthesis there so
this returns
the charge
right okay yeah that was it
because this returns a boolean in our
case it's always true because you know
we haven't implemented a true payment
system so we're just assuming the
payment works
but we do have way in case it fails to
return payment error
so that's uh it's uh something we could
do later if we want that's getting into
the real world so we're not going to go
there okay it all compiles
and looks fine so
you can kind of use this you can request
items so you got all this storefront
now we're in client world so
we want to uh just basically do stuff
like
our storefront
dot request item
and we'll have a return code here just
make it auto for now
and what item do we request i don't know
we need a sku so we'll put in some
random numbers
and
then we want our payment
to be passed here as well
in
you know if we're really going further
with this we could say shipping detail
all that stuff but
uh maybe that would be a great proxy
actually to put the shipping
on that because that's essential
essentially what you do with proxies is
you usually add some additional stuff
to whatever it was before
let's go ahead and display
our output here
and we get code zero
what is code zero
well we can take a look at it and say
item not found
okay interesting
yep that actually makes sense there is
no two three four in here but if we look
for two three three item let's see what
happens
actually let's just uh copy all this
code
and let's hit play again
it is oh we just we're saying return
code twice
so let's go like that
okay
so for the first one we got a zero our
item not found the second one we got a
six which is the cost there's the cost
so that works perfectly okay
so if we take it a step further and make
a proxy
we can do some special stuff
so while our current item request works
fine
what we could do is uh we could
uh say we'll put another front on it so
that we can gather shipping before we
request the item
so what we do is we just go class
um
proxy or
address
and we will take in
or we
are going to include this item request
here as part of this class
now if this were a pure virtual
interface class we would want to hold a
pointer to it
uh let's actually just real quick make
that base interface let's just call it a
request all right and
in here this is where we're going to
have
this
version
all the same stuff here
this time it's going to be equal zero
so that way i have to implement it in
this item quest
and we do need
the obstructor here too
there is a virtual
ad inventory as well
so we could put that in here
and make that equal zero too so now we
have an interface that can't be
instantiated on its own it has to be
overridden and all these virtuals
declared
with override
i don't think we need virtual over here
on the left side but i'm going to leave
it to see if pilot complains now this
inventory could probably go up to here
yeah and that would be fine
so there we go now we've got an actual
interface
so in this case what we would do here
so we call this one
just is this interface here
let's make a proxy let's make a proxy of
the item quest
so here's the proxy for address on
west um
i want to make this descriptive and long
proxy for address before buy okay super
long last name but just just roll with
it it's fine
just want to make it clear
so in this we already got all this
request stuff but of course it needs
overwritten or so you would think but
we can make a private member here that
is called
item quest to make pointer
all right and then probably we're going
to have to have
the constructor so that we can set this
and it would look something like this uh
proxy we have this whole name
constructor and we want to put in
this item like so
let's call it uh
fighting brick
all right and then we want to just
instantiate this like
so just do new
by
pass this pointer
all right
we've got to de-reference it like that
and we got brackets over here for
everything else but that should be fine
all right then we want to of course a
destructor publicly here
that just deletes the item request
instructs and uh that should be mostly
ready to go so we can add in some more
private stuff here
uh that we want to do because we already
know that this item request is gonna
have this whole instantiation here
but now since this
proxy for address
implements this request we also have to
implement
these still
which is actually okay but it also means
that this can stand in uh in this
interface so rather than the old item
requests now we can uh
now we can put roxy on top of it so i'll
go ahead and show that
so first of all we need to implement a
few more methods here like uh
basically all of these
and these overwritten ones we also need
to overwrite but rather than call
everything we've already called and
rewrite this sort of thing
just do it like this
just push it
to there
does that make sense
that's just so long
and same thing here but the whole point
of the proxy is to do a little
additional stuff so
that's probably what we want to do and
have some private functions let's do a
uh check payment here and now we said
that this is for address
so
uh you know we could add on an address
and write a whole new function
for all of these
that does such a thing
but let's keep it a little simpler okay
let's let's just make this
check a few things uh before doing
the request
uh
check before
item request that's what we're going to
call it that's what this proxy is going
to be called
so forget about the address we're going
to totally skip over the address factor
overall of course you'd want to work
that into your real system but uh let's
keep the complications down so what we
want to do here if we add inventory for
example that can probably stay the same
we could add a check before and after if
we want uh
yeah let's actually do it let's say
maybe we want a little bit of a log
uh so let's go
one
log
um
inventory
and this will just take in the uh
whatever details
about it
so rather than being function obviously
we could even just put this code right
here because we're going to call this
and we're just gonna say
we'll just do a cl
tempted to add
you know we can
you know we could put further checks in
here to say like if it added and all
that kind of stuff you can do a whole
bunch of additional queries up in here
i'm just going to keep it simple but we
might do a before and after see if it
actually got added that sort of thing
but for sake of time i'm going to kind
of skip over that and just just put this
uh
this click attempted to add sku
so
that should
give you an idea because essentially the
rest of the stuff would be the same so
now we still have an ad inventory but
now also logs so that's one thing you
can do and we could do the same thing
with this request item for example we
could have a
payment check or something
it turns out true or false just takes in
this payment and we could do our own
pre-check on the payment if we wanted
before trying to actually charge
uh
pre-check payment for legality or
something you know just some basic stuff
make sure that the card isn't uh
expired or something like that sure
account exists
slash card
isn't expired
etc
we're gonna assume pass for now
so we're just gonna return true
for now but
pretend this was
the elaborate system that did some
additional checks right
so we you know we could do that here
and the reason this would be good is we
could not even like maybe we don't even
want to send the request like if we know
that the payment's not good let's not
even go further so we could go yeah
uh
so
if not paid so if this returns false
then we would return
i don't know we could go ahead and stick
with the original payment error we'll
return
negative one a little sooner here
it's a little proxy check and we could
also if we want we could we could do a
initial query
on the item skew maybe i don't know
that's going to be kind of hard because
the way we got it worked up but uh
that's the point of the proxy here is to
basically be able to add some
functionality and pretend to be the
interface that you want so let's have a
look back over here so we have our
storefront it's got items what if
instead of item request it was now a
check before item request
now you can see that it doesn't really
like this right okay so let's put the
old one back let's go
now let's make this
proxy store
now of course it wants the same one so
or it needs
it needs something to instantiate
and it wants a pointer so we're going to
have to do a reference here
now we've got a proxy store and we can
still do the same thing
on this proxy store instead of our
storefront
and get some return codes and whatnot so
let's go ahead and have a check of that
we've also got new ad inventory
functions so we could test one of those
let's go ahead and just put one down
here
and this one should log it's just add
some different details
ninth man i'll say two in stock
so make sure the
proxy store here
proxy it
real store
proxy of it and here's our client
run through the proxy okay so let's have
a run of this code we should definitely
see the add inventory these should work
just fine
and uh
well we got an error okay so we need to
include iostream in this header
you need to have a c out somewhere
and i'll say play
and there we go
so we got an attempted to add sku
so that worked okay we got a couple
return codes negative one now i didn't
really expect this i thought that uh one
of the return codes would be successful
we're getting negative one
whereas item is not found
so there's something happening there
that's not working quite right because
this one
should work okay
so we can put a break point here put
this in debug and see what's going on
hit f11
and then hit f5 to go all the way down
here and then f11 go into this
and let's see what's happening here
looks like our payment check is not
might be backwards it's returning true
which turns into a false skips over very
good um
oh we're not returning here so we should
be returning that because we want to
return whatever this returns so that's
the entire problem with the code i
believe it says stop
go back to release
and hit play now it looks better more
like what we expect turn code 0 for the
ones not found return code 6 for charge
6
and that's doing it through the proxy so
you can see how proxies could be
interesting and also scary for example a
hacker might put a proxy over something
and just skim a little of the payment
off the top or something like that but
uh you know that's the scary
black hat
the whole operation but generally you're
just adding some functionality hope you
guys have enjoyed this episode and have
a better understanding of what a proxy
is and how to implement it c plus plus
this code will be up on github enjoy the
video or learn something consider
hitting the like button and uh if you
want to see more of these videos
consider supporting the channel i do
have a patreon it's up on the channel
page a link to it is and we have a
discord if you want to talk about code
and all kinds of cool stuff like that so
uh yeah have a peek around if you want
i'll see you
later map go tech tutorial server and
out
[Music]